6 Minute English From BBCLearningEnglish.com
Hello, this is 6 Minute English from BBCLearningEnglish, I'm Phil.
And I'm Beth.
If you use the internet and nearly everyone does, you've probably read headlines like this.
You won't believe what plastic surgery this celebrity has had done.
Known as clickbait, headlines like these are used to grab your attention and make you read more.
But now a new trend called ragebait is spreading across social media.
Ragebait is online content designed to make you angry or outraged.
In this programme we'll explore the trend of ragebaiting and as usual we'll learn some useful
new vocabulary, all of which you can find on our website, BBCLearningEnglish.com.
Great, but first it's time for my question, Beth, which is about the two terms we've been using.
Clickbait and ragebait. Both contain the word bait. But what is his actual meaning?
Is bait a strong feeling of anger?
Be food, put on a hook to catch fish or animals or see a piece of computer software.
I am fairly confident that it is bait food, put on a hook.
Okay, well we'll find out the correct answer later in the programme.
Here's how ragebait works. A creator posts a provocative piece of content online,
a message maybe or a video, people see it, feel outraged and comment angrily.
Others see it, like it and share it around. On either way the content creates interest,
increases internet traffic and makes money for the creator.
Here's marketing strategist Andrea Jones explaining more to Megan Lawton,
presenter of BBC World Service programme Business Daily.
The more content they create, the more engagement they get, the more that they get paid.
And so they will do anything, some creators will do anything to get more views because the more views
they get, the more that they get paid, even if those views are negative or inciting rage and anger.
Andrea, how is ragebait different to clickbait or other online tactics?
As a marketer, I'm always coaching my clients and talking to them about using hooks in their
marketing, right? And I think the difference between a hook and ragebait or even it's a long-lost
cousin clickbait content, when we think about a hook, to me a hook accurately reflects what's in
that piece of content. And it comes from a place of trust, whereas ragebaiting content is designed
to be manipulative. Andrea says the more reaction a post gets, the more money the creator makes,
even if the reactions are hateful. She uses the structure, the more one thing happens,
the more something else happens, to show that as one thing happens repeatedly, another thing
increases as a result. For example, the more you practise English, the more you'll improve.
It doesn't matter that the content is designed to incite outrage, to encourage unpleasant or violent
reactions. That's why Andrea thinks ragebait is worse than clickbait. While clickbait is more
truthful about its content, ragebait is manipulative, meaning it tries to influence something to its
own advantage. So it's not hard to see why many people think ragebait is toxic. So if you're
wondering why people react in the first place, listen as Dr. William Brady explains the psychology
behind ragebait to BBC World Services business daily. If you are an influencer and you want to
figure out, well, how do I get more eyeballs on my content? Well, you need to exploit those biases
we have in our psychology, because that's the content we'll pay more attention to. In turn,
that's the content that algorithms will amplify, which ultimately means more advertising revenue.
Influences want more eyeballs on their content, more people to view their website or social media posts,
and use human psychology to do it. Psychologically speaking, we all have biases. Feelings which are
often unconscious, either for or against a certain idea or group of people. Biasis are emotional,
and since listening to our emotions has been vital to the evolution of the human species,
creators know that provoking our emotions will grab our attention.
So what can be done to combat ragebait? Well, we could all take a moment to think before reacting,
and remember that by sharing something outrageous, you might be making things worse,
while also making the creator richer. Okay, Phil, let's reveal the answer to your question. You
asked me what bait is. I did. And the correct answer is B. Food put on a hook to catch a fish or
an animal. Isn't that what you said, Ben? It is, yes. Right again. Okay, let's recap the vocabulary
we've learnt in the programme, starting with ragebait. Social media content designed to provoke
anger, thereby encouraging people to engage with it. The structure, the more, the more, describes
the situation when one thing happening repeatedly results in another thing happening too.
To incite someone means to encourage them to do or feel something unpleasant or violent.
The adjective manipulative describes trying to influence or control someone to your own advantage.
Eyeballs is an informal word for the number of people viewing a particular website or television
programme. And finally, biases are feelings, often unconscious, either for or against an idea
or a group of people. Once again, our six minutes are up. Goodbye for now. Bye.